here's what would happen if you lived in  the paleozoic era  first of all you'd breathe a little  easier  an abundance of cyanobacteria would be  pumping more oxygen into the atmosphere  you'd need to live near the shoreline to  be close to all the resources you'd need  to stay alive  although you'd ruled the land as an apex  predator watch out for the ocean that's  shark territory  you'd watch as europe and north america  slowly merged to become the chilly super  continent known as gondwana  you'd witness ice ages jawless fish  swimming through the sea and glaciers  melting  with trees covering the surface of earth  for the first time you'd be able to  build shelter and even start a fire but  at the end of this era in the permian  period  96 of life on earth would die out in the  biggest extinction ever  in short you'd witness the most radical  changes in earth's history so